it's not about you if trust me if the
company's successful
and you're a leader in the company it's
going to reflect quite well on you
so you don't need to be the star
[Music]
peter wexler thank you for being on 20
million leaders how are you
oh i'm doing great michael thanks very
much where are you calling from right
now
i'm calling from my uh covid pandemic
office hideout in downtown palo alto
wonderful so we're neighbors i'm right
here on forest avenue at hippo
but it's really really great to have you
and i'm really excited to talk to you
about teamwork
uh you've been a part of numerous teams
you know
in various positions both on the end of
you know the the company as you know vp
of engineering
and you know really internally and and
seeing through acquisitions joining huge
companies you mentioned siemens
of over 400 000 people internationally
and on the other side also you know
being a board member on various
companies
it sounds like a different type of
teamwork i'd love to learn about both
experiences
and i'd love to explore with you over
these next 19 minutes or so
what makes a team strong what makes a
team perhaps
weaker than the others so you know take
me along your journey peter let's start
from the beginning walk me a little bit
about
you know where you come from and and
your insight into teamwork
um let's see um undergraduate uh
electrical engineering was always
interested in that stuff when i was a
kid
you know science engineering ham radio
all that
stuff um and uh actually through that i
got i had a strong interest in biology
as well so i ended up getting a graduate
degree in biomedical engineering
imaging of the retina and a lot of image
processing which was great
and i worked in that field actually i
actually worked for an israeli company
called el sint
in the early days which was a pioneer in
nuclear medicine and ultrasound
but um i end for a whole variety of
reasons i ended up in the networking
field about
very very early on you know before there
was the web before there was anything
else
and i've actually spent a fair time of
my career
in the networking space both for large
companies but also
with some very early stage companies
from zero
from maybe 15 people um
and for the whole issue of teamwork one
of the ones i like to focus on
is juniper networks so um juniper
networks which is one of the major
players with the infrastructure that's
in
the internet um i was the first vp of
engineering i started maybe when there
were 15 or 17 people
oh wow okay and you know
there are a number of reasons why and
when sort of ran the company we
ultimately had 675 people in engineering
and we were
you know half a billion dollars uh you
know by the time i moved on
but um a lot of lessons that i learned
there from the folks i worked with
and so the first thing was when you're
building a team
in addition to the key technical skills
that you're looking for
you have to look at the uh you know how
people play together
and how is an individual going to be as
part of a
of a team because it's not about these
days
one individual can't do the whole thing
especially when you're doing complex
things
you know the thing i mentioned to you
michael i like to say
any given day is the best thing you've
ever done in your life or the worst
thing you've ever done in your life
and i like to say the average just needs
to be above zero
right and then it's then it's a good
thing but um
so one of the things that we did at
juniper was we were
a very um extensive process during
interview and it wasn't so much
yeah there were technical reviews and
that sort of thing but it was really you
know a group of folks
trying to understand the personality of
the individual
and how they would fit within the team
which is not to say you want everybody
to look the same
because people looked way different
there are a lot of different people but
it's
how would they play as part of the team
because when challenges happen
you need to be able to solve them in a
really constructive way
and on the other hand when wonderful
things happen
there's nobody better to celebrate with
than you know folks who are focused on
the same goal
and so at one level um
uh in in terms of building a company
that's teamwork
you mentioned boards and that's a lesson
that i actually learned the hard way
there was was a well-funded company that
i
was asked to join it was maybe about 20
people i came in to help sort out
engineering
and you know it had the reputation of
the individuals on the board
was all stellar but unfortunately
um too many egos in the room
folks did not play well together and
again when
there were some tough times and some
tough decisions had to be made
the team was incapable of of making
decisions
so it's a t so a board so so board you
know
group of a group of board members that
are each individually are stellar but
coming in together
don't seem to find the the units and the
harmony to to come up with you know with
good results
actually this reminds me of a beautiful
quote that small shatan also from jay
ventures mentioned to me
just a few days ago in our call he said
you know that to be
in if you want to be a good leader learn
to check your ego at the door
and he and i just loved that you know
that you know that
imagery of checking the ego at the door
and walking in and he referred that as
to as to the
whole j ventures mantra that we come in
and you know we have 100
people in the room you know looking at
deals and every person
feels that you know while they can
contribute they also have so much to
learn from everybody else
uh so i i think that's exactly right you
know the other piece is
so you're not the other thing is
if you're hiring the best people you can
what you find is you're hiring type a
people
now it's it's it's like an arranged
marriage there's no reason there's no
reason it should work
you're slamming all these people
together everybody has success
everybody's got an ego
it won't work so your job as a leader is
to basically keep the thing from going
off the rails
until you get til you get to whatever
milestone is important now
having said that you're you're not gonna
everybody who's going to come in is not
going to be even keeled and that's
not what you want so the trick is you
know i always say
i give you more latitude in terms of
your
enthusiasm you know based upon you know
how much of a contributor you are and
how you help the rest of the team so you
know
you know every so often people have a
meltdown or whatever else but if they're
good contributors
and they're working well we understand
and frankly teams understand that
you know it's a with a small team
everybody knows how much everybody's
contributing
and everybody gives everybody a break if
if people are contributing
so you're not going to get people who
are uniform and smiley and wonderful
everybody's going to be very intense
because they believe
but uh you know like andy grove used to
say right you decide and commit which is
we can be passionate about our
discussions and we got to get it on the
table
but once we decide on the direction we
got to move forward because
if we keep going you know you got even
if it's small steps moving forward is
key
and uh so how do you but but how do you
sort of facilitate that that that moving
forward mantra especially as you're you
know you're working on these various
companies a lot of them are critical
infrastructure
a lot of these you know are perhaps
longer term projects that you don't
celebrate every day and you don't see
progression every day
so as a team leader how can i continue
to motivate a team and to continue that
mindset of moving forward and making
decisions we're keeping everybody
passionate if we're looking at long-term
commitments and not short-term goals
so so um so
one of the things is important is
transparency
right which doesn't mean everything's on
the table but being transparent because
you know it's particularly when things
get a little bit tough that's when
conspiracy theories start
you know i don't know if it's i don't
know if it's engineers or
or it's the same with biologists or
whatever but if something's not going
right or they see that
you're worried absolutely the worst
thing that's possible would be dreamt up
right and that's usually not the case
right so so
keep a check who is i forget who said it
was you know the
the leader has a long tail right so you
better be careful how you swing that
thing
so yeah so you need to be transparent
about what's going on
and and a lot of times you know there's
a lot of moving parts in these
these businesses and people don't always
have a background or an understanding or
the experience and you need to be able
to
translate and explain to folks what the
context is
up you know we're going out we're
raising money it's taking a longer time
we actually had to raise the second
round of funding for a company we
started
during the recession you know took twice
as long that it was before right
everybody got a little bit worried but
you
need to explain what's going on don't
leave things a mystery
and uh it's just all about helping
people feel comfortable and you do it
one-on-one
or you do it with a group and
you know hiding things is not good being
transparent where you can
and helping to put things in context you
know is important and that's
frankly if you have a good board for a
company bringing in
a board member or two who has a very
good perspective
and having that person sit with the
company so you're not the only person
you know it's not like you're just
mouthing you know platitudes
you're bringing in some other folks
who've got some perspective who can
you know help folks so peter it sounds
like a lot of this foundation
is built upon respect open-mindedness
along with
you know this idea of contributing to
the team and being a team player
talk to me a little bit about you know
this idea of respect how do you
facilitate respect
and then the next question will be
open-mindedness within a team because at
the end the team is not just
you know a performance-based team where
you just you know check off goals
you're what you're talking about here is
that every person needs to be
contributing you need to come in unison
and complement each other
and to me it sounds that a fun
fundamental aspect of this is the
respect
right yeah it's important right and
there's respect in different dimensions
right technical respect
human respect you know etc etc right
you know it's how culture starts from
the top
and actually we see this in some
companies in silicon valley that have
been written about right they say that
it's like the fish
it rots from the head right right so not
my words but other things
uh but it's true so you know it's it's
the environment that you establish from
the beginning
and and also it's how you treat you know
there are going to be people
who while they may be great contributors
and be required to be around for a
certain period of time
you know as the company grows it just
may not be a good fit and frankly
i need to deal with those and take
action because if you don't
it's everybody recognizes that you're
not taking action and you tolerate that
sort of
behavior so you know it's it's
you got to set the culture from the
beginning it's how you behave how you
expect the team to behave when things go
off the rails
how you deal with them um
you know i mean that's so that crisis
management when things go off the rails
how do you deal with them are there you
know personal experiences that you've
had
or anything any any key moments that
you've observed
where you saw either people come on top
or
or you know not succeed through these
crises
um i have had situations where things
have been
brought to a head um because of
certain individuals and
you know i would so if a particular
individual is
problematic in a number of different
dimensions not so much because they're
not technical but because
it's their behavior and and and how they
create dysfunction throughout the group
so you know i spent a lot of time
walking through parking lots with people
you know as
as groups grew i started to ask myself
what do you contribute to this
technically because i felt more like i
was being
a psychologist or psychiatrist it's like
that's hilarious the office is open
people come and shut the door the next
guy comes in shuts the door
but but so and too many times walking
around the parking lot and you know
with some of that one-on-one you could
smooth it but it gets to a point where
you can't and you
the hope is that you it and it's
particularly tough with small teams
because everybody's critical but
when you start to to see this or get
wind of this
then you need to start a long-term
strategy of saying
i think in the long run this person is
not going to work out what am i going to
do
because at some point this person's
going to have to go and how do i
prepare other folks to take on things
how do i bring other people in and then
you ultimately need to
take action now having said that most of
the cases don't involve ejecting a
person
right it involves working with people
individually one-on-one
about how they can how they can grow and
be more effective
it's not they usually don't want to be a
bad person they
a lot of times somebody will have
experience in a previous company and a
style of behavior that worked well for
them
right and it's a matter of helping them
grow and learn that there are other ways
to get things done
and in many cases actually this works
it's just
you know bad behavior that maybe
especially if somebody's you know
hasn't worked for 20 years right you
know if they're younger
they brought bad behavior from somewhere
else so maybe a little bit of mentoring
with myself or somebody else and
give them some perspective on how they
might be able to accomplish things a
little bit differently
so given the you know everything we've
talked about here as i approach you know
my own leadership positions down the
line and now now i get to be a part of a
wonderful team here at hippo and the j
ventures and i get to experience really
incredible people
an incredible mentorship both you know
bottom up and and top
down but as i continue along my path and
become
you know a technical team leader myself
or potentially a ceo down the line
what are the the core things that i need
to keep in mind
as i'm growing the team and as i'm you
know creating this family that
is going to to work with me on you know
bringing a product to life
uh so so i i think just enjoy i'm asking
you hard questions
well you know so you're the value of the
answer is equivalent to the amount of
time that i put into thinking about it
so um number one i think just
intellectual curiosity and curiosity in
general is a trait that's important to
have
you know and the other thing is you know
they used to call it an hp management by
walking around
which is you know you you want to be in
touch
at all levels of an organization as
organizations grow
sometimes people are in touch with say
one level
you know below them but you know you
need to really understand what's going
on with the organization and you need to
have many touch points within the
organization so you really understand
what's going on with the organization
you need to you know respect the role of
other leaders
and not go around them but try to work
with them to help them be more effective
because if you want to grow as a leader
and you want to scale within an
organization you can't do everything
yourself so how do you empower and grow
other leaders around you
right as you said check the ego at the
door it's not about you
if trust me if the company's successful
and you're a leader in the company
it's going to reflect quite well on you
so you don't need to be the star
and and i think that's been the case
with me i'm i'm not the star
in any of the adventures that i've been
part of for the most part
and and but you know what the success of
the ventures that i
have been successful in has served me
extremely well
um in my career so you know those are
those are just a few things that
off the top of my head wonderful peter
what are you up to now what
what really excites you these days
whether it's with investments or you
know the industry or the ecosystem
um what do you get hyped about
what do i get hyped about um uh
so there's um there there are a whole
range of companies that i'm working with
some more actively some more passively
and obviously involved with j
ventures which is actually a wonderful
group it's just it's a it's a really
great group but um there are a number of
things in the machine learning space
as applied to some really tough
problems whether it's in healthcare drug
discovery
or um uh sort of other
other problems in the industry and um so
i'm frankly doing a massive amount of
learning
from a lot of other folks who are really
passionate in some of these spaces
and again working with
you groups of young folks i mean just
the energy is is great you know
some of us get if you've done a few
early stage companies right
you can get you understand how hard it
is but if you're young and you haven't
worked with that many you don't realize
how hard it is
so everybody's got great energy so um
but there are some things in that space
that are are actually really really
exciting
so and then how so you're coming in and
you're and you're getting exposed to all
these different companies you're
involved in them
both you know in advisory roles board
seats and
what is it why specifically you know
machine learning for solving difficult
problems i mean there's so many
different things that could happen
is this a recent you know passion that
you're developing or is this something
that you've grown over the years
you know it 30 years ago there was
something called lisp
which was the first stab at ai back in
in in times when i was actually working
for siemens in
in industrial automation and um
you could see back then the ultimate
value of some of this but
unfortunately our compute you know did
not scale to really address the problem
and it's only
recently that we have some architectures
that are able to deal with things like
complex
neural networks and other things like
that that you can now
start to do things like you know
self-driving vehicles
or recommender systems or other sorts of
things
so it's something that i've always sort
of or i remember
when i was in boston met with some of
the folks at mit who were the early
folks
in machine learning and ai and again it
was interesting but something you kind
of stick in the back of your head
realizing that it kind of isn't going
anywhere for a while
um so so just the fact that it's sort of
you know the technology exists now to
actually do some of these things it's
interesting
having said that unfortunately my
interests are very broad so i have some
involvement
a little bit of involvement in biotech
and in few other places
so it's uh it's a curse of having broad
interests and a lot of curiosity and
you know that's the problem i love it i
love it no and i definitely you know i
i aspire to to be exactly that to have
that curiosity and to go both you know
in depth into certain fields but go
agnostic and others and be able to be
open-minded and get exposed to all these
different opportunities
peter before we go i want to thank you
again for for your generosity and and
for the inspiration i i've learned
so much through this conversation but
before we go i have to ask you for three
words
that you would use to describe yourself
or any of your you know partners
in board seats or or companies would
describe peter wechsler
ooh um the hardest question of all
you know i think i think i think i've
been an effective leader
in terms of and and have been in terms
of
growing teams and growing teams rapidly
i think i've been an effective leader
i think that i am a very even keeled
individual
other than maybe once a quarter i don't
explode i'm just
generally you know i i uh
and i so i don't freak out when you know
hits the fan
good and uh and whatever else uh and
and maybe just you know in insanely
curious
i was just about to say that is the
third word because that resonates very
very well through
this conversation peter thank you very
much today this was wonderful
and uh and and stay safe and stay
healthy oh thanks michael and best to
you and i'm sure i'll see you at a
uh meeting jay of jventures sometimes
thank you take care take care man be
well